des millions de voix s'élèvent à travers
le monde alors que le mot clic moi aussi
serait pas comme une traîne et de poudre
les témoignages qui se comptent
maintenant vraiment par dizaines de
milliers octobre 2017 le Québec et lui
aussi frappé de plein fouet par la vague
de dénonciation qui déferlent à travers
le monde des voies de milliers de femmes
s'élèvent en utilisant le mot clé moi
aussi elle détaille les inconduites
sexuelles qu'ils ont subi
quelque chose soit mis à l'avant-plan ça
a ouvert la conversation j'ai
l'impression que ça a libéré la parole
et que ça a été positif dans ce sens-là
cinq ans plus tard le mouvement est
encore présent dans la mémoire
collective et ses impacts au sein de la
société se font sentir Mitou a été
finalement une vague frappée
suffisamment fort pour ouvrir la boîte
puis faire en sorte que il y a comme un
consensus social qui a bougé par rapport
justement au fait que les crimes à
caractère sexuel la violence sexuelle
c'est une vraie violence puisque les
victimes de ce type de crime là
les vrais victimes un tribunal
spécialisé en matière de violence
sexuelle et conjugales à vue le jour au
Québec un projet pilote est actuellement
les sites dans une dizaine de districts
de la province il y a une prise de
conscience il y a des efforts qui sont
faits pour prouver que le système de
justice peut répondre adéquatement au
besoin des vitres la réflexion est bien
entamée mais sur le terrain les
intervenants remarquent il y a encore
beaucoup de travail à faire que les
changements sont à géométrie variable
c'est pourquoi la création d'une loi
cadre dans les écoles primaires et
secondaires de la province pour prévenir
les violences sexuelles et réclamer la
lutte contre les violences sexuelle
n'est pas terminée je pense que
socialement il faut qu'on poursuive
cette réflexion collective là et qu'on
se refuse est-ce que et qu'on n'est pas
cette tentation là de se réfugier
derrière le tribunal pour dire que les
problèmes sont réglés et tout ne se
règle pas par le biais des tribunaux
criminels d'autres actions comme la
poursuite du dialogue et une meilleure
éducation peuvent être prises
collectivement un long travail qui
nécessiter la collaboration de tous ici
qui me permettra au Canada Montréal